I want to start with congrats on being
able to make another season to party
down I'm a huge fan of the show season
I've seen the first five episodes of
season three and laughed like a crazy
person so I'm just gonna say um congrats
thank you yeah it's I mean honestly
that's the reaction that gives me
confidence that maybe the fans will also
feel the same way it's so happy like
that's the biggest worry is that um will
be released and and people will be
disappointed because they've been
waiting for it for so long it's the only
fool that people come up to me and
they're like are you guys making more
party down I love party down I'm like I
hope so man I want to be there more than
you want to see it
um so here we are we finally did it I
hope I hope it's received well my thing
is that I'm a greedy SOB now that you
Vision six isn't enough yeah so my
question is do you think there's a
chance of more or was this like a one
and done thing I hope there's a chance
of more this isn't obviously a decision
that I get to make but I do hope that
with
um you know uh uh with a good reception
as we come out into the world again for
season three that you know if the fan
base is there and and grows a little bit
I hope that we will have
um the opportunity to do a fourth one
that's the dream yeah I also like uh
listen I would have been happy with you
know 20 episodes but I'll take the six
you know whatever I whatever I can get
so I I definitely want to know what was
it like like the night before you're
getting ready to step on set for that
first day of filming
um had you re-watched the first two
seasons were you actually a little bit
nervous to go film or was it all
excitement for me it's excitement it
isn't nerves uh like you know when I was
younger when I you know in my like I
don't know I guess I grew up out here
too so it's a it's a different
bye but um
every time before the first day of any
job really this one in particular I just
can't get sleep I get I'm too excited to
figure out what's going on I think it's
there's more anxiety with other jobs
because you don't know what you're
getting into and so day one could be
anything but with especially with this
it's just excitement you know I I I just
want to get back to playing with my
friends like this is summer camp at its
best
um
yeah
did I that didn't answer your question
what was your question no no no where do
I go now no it totally worked okay so
um I don't want to do spoilers but one
of the episodes of the first five uh has
to do with um everyone doing drugs and
I'm curious when
it's weird that you would pick that
episode anyway continue no but I want to
specifically talk about when you read in
the script that everyone's going to be
high and you you know are you excited
about that or are you a little bit
nervous because you have to protrude you
have to be sober while portraying being
up
we have to be sober
uh I mean wait it was fun it's it's I
think it it's even more fun you know
because the was the end of season two is
the Constance Carmel wedding and I'm
really high in the bathroom writing my
manuscript and that was just me and so I
I think there's some there's something
more
um
I mean that was fun don't get me wrong
but there's something more fun about
everybody kind of going on a journey
like that together it almost feels like
you really are doing mushrooms together
whoops no spoilers um but that you know
it you all get to like go down travel
that road together
um it makes it more fun because you're
all exploring what that reality feels
like you know while you're eating
mushroom chocolates by the truckload how
much did John tell you about the ark and
what was going to be happening
um you know before filming began and how
much were you finding out script by
Script uh I mean I had a conversation
with him before we started shooting and
he hinted at the evolution of
um Roman and you know um the the teasing
of
uh you know certain plot points that are
really fun to to play out and I think
the most fun going into this third
season is it was less about Standalone
episodes the way the first two seasons
were where the real arcs only existed
for
um Adam and Lizzy that that romance was
the the real development that happened
episode to episode but in in this new
season I think we all have
um arcs on some wavelength that are it's
just more fun to play in that you know
the development of the characters and
the development of of the stories as a
whole and how they intertwine I totally
agree it's also how different
um television is from when you guys
first made party down to where it is now
yeah it was also built uh with a
different with a specific formula you
know I think the structure of the show
was meant to allow for different people
to come in in case somebody couldn't
make it for season three should we get
picked up for the that third season way
back when and now it's the show doesn't
exist unless we get our people back like
it really is about the crew that's
that's how we have this opportunity to
come back is because of the success of
the first two seasons so you can't just
do it with a whole new group of people I
don't think
um but thankfully for me because I got
the call to come back
um but yeah and you know hopefully if we
get to do another season we'll
um be able to have Lizzy back and have
it be a proper reunion of everybody
um
and hopefully she doesn't set the
standard where somebody else can't do it
next season or something
um yeah you've done a lot of stuff
through your in the last 20 years
um if someone has actually never seen
anything you've done what is the first
thing you want them watching and why I
don't I'd rather just talk to them and
have a conversation
right don't don't watch anything
I mean like what am I the most proud of
that's a hard question no no not even
not even that is like maybe there's a
role or something that you're you know
that didn't get enough people watching
it and you want them to see that I did a
uh an episode a year on uh life in
pieces and every year I got to do a
really fun character there that's I'm
unrecognizable I think it was uh my
friend Justin created that show and
asked if I would come and play uh a pest
exterminator and and uh
and so I I had it contingent on the
pronunciation of a particular word which
really was where I derived a lot of the
character from and I just got to play
like I I just like
I like I just like playing I mean party
down is is really
um a great place for anyone to start
with any of our careers and and I think
there's a lot of
um you know the spider web of talent and
and opportunities and shows and movies
that that come from this group is really
incredible but I think party down really
stands
um stands alone in a really special way
for all of us I'm almost out of time I
definitely have to say congratulations
on Tulsa King hey thanks so much yeah
it's it's crazy I didn't I didn't expect
it to kind of get this kind of following
I mean I don't get me wrong I think
Stallone still deserves the audience
that he's getting here but I guess I
just didn't expect it there's so much to
watch now you kind of don't anticipate
anything you know being stand out uh
when Stallone signed on for that I was
like and I will be watching I watched
the whole season because I'm a fan of
Sly and he doesn't do TV yeah he's great
I I really enjoyed working with him I
definitely have to ask you uh do you
know when you start filming the second
season I we don't have dates yet I think
they're working out so many details we
don't even know where we're going to do
it this year so or this next season so
I'm excited to find out everything
um I don't think they've dug into
scripts or anything yet I could be wrong
but you know the impending writer strike
certainly would urge anyone to get get
moving